speaker metea meanie started this
project in his free time which off
it's another class of project so when
he's speaking about Python today his PhD
is an optimizing compiler so a free time
project and optimizing python is a
little more impactful than perhaps some
of my free time projects so from this
talk I think you'll learn a little bit
more about how we can squeezle even more
performance out of our pythonic code and
I'm excited to learn about what he's
going to share I don't need to make
thank you hello everyone I'm here to
talk about Python so patron is our pet
project that we are doing on our free
time so it was started two years ago by
surgical tone of a friend of mine we did
our PhD in the same lab so I joined him
to to walk on this project and we're
sponsored by the company i'm walking on
I'm working for silicon for the first
year and carrick brunei is the stud
developer very active is also doing this
on his free time so yeah we are just
doing this for fun and you enjoy it so
yeah it's Sunday morning I know it would
be hard for everyone I'm not as good as
James power how are you enjoyed this
stuff yesterday so I will try to do my
best to keep you wake up right so quick
disclaimer just the all the software and
the hardware i use to show you the
number i will give you have to take into
account that i did some benchmark on my
personal laptop so it's really not like
it just a rough idea of the numbers you
can get especially the comparison it's
not intended to be fair against the
competition of course I'm not a Python
esta originally but i'm interested in
performance my daily job doesn't use at
all python I'm doing driver level c code
assembly code multi-threaded c++
framework and GPU programming so yeah i
don't have as many jokes as a crease
laughs now yesterday but what I'm good
at is
flame war so maybe you can try so my
claim is that we C++ primer are more
social than you guys and I have some
support for my claim just that we
compile code so you don't have any you
don't have any excuse to go fun like us
and even this talk is compiled because
I've wrote it in latex so give me 10
seconds of free time every time I
recompile it so but I heard that not
everyone is as passionate she does in
C++ and low level code as I am I don't
understand why but it seems that people
tend to prefer high level programming
framework to prototype their tools it
seems that many of them tend to use
Python so it seems that what Python has
is a huge ecosystem a lot of tools lot
of libraries that helps you build
programs very fast I don't know much
about Python but it doesn't really
matter because all i care is this little
white spot if this big black circle is
your program then this little white dot
is the part that i know you because it's
what take time what it's ups your CPU
and this is what you want to optimize
and this is what I care about so I don't
need to understand the rest of your
applications so let's go quickly what we
offer with patron with a regular ipython
session I so this is the Rosenberg
function just as an example applied on a
limpiar ray and you can see that it
takes a few milliseconds 35 milliseconds
and to use Python it's not that hard and
I thing you have to do is load an
extension of course a bit of magic and
then add this one single green
annotation with the type
which is just a Python commands it's
going to be ignored by Python but patron
will use it and then you can just run
your benchmark again and it goes just a
little bit faster means like 290 so yeah
and that's pretty easy to use so how it
works I will go into a little bit more
details later so we take a python module
we take eventually some OpenMP
annotation and patron we process this
python module using the Python ist
module so pipe Tran is fully written in
Python and it generates a c++ meter
program I will explain a bit later what
I mean and then we feed this program to
the compiler the host compiler g + + or
clung and with a bunch of library boosts
python of course but also Python in + +
which is our own runtime library and
some other libraries like NT to I will
talk about it later we generate a night
shift module that can be imported and
used as any python module so our goals
so performance first so we sacrifice
some language feature we only under a
subset of Python and the thing that we
don't handle are just useless stuff
nobody use it I guess last class evil
introspection polymorphic viable right
yeah backward compatibility matters so
we don't change Python it's pure python
it stays calm vegetable when you've
write code for python respite ran in
mind it is compatible with Python and
this is important because it means your
code won't be specialized Popeye Tron
you can see use it normally and there is
no exit costs or entre cast for Python
the entre cost is low the exit cost is
known so it's not a tool or you are
stick to it and we have our modular
compilation which means you can compute
you compile one module and it will
interact with the rest of your code we
focus on numerical camels so I showed
you the hot spot earlier
and to do that we do a lot of static
analysis we do vectorization
paralyzation when we can yeah the reason
we do static computation is that it by
its time for complex analyzes so why do
we use C++ so modern C++ cincy plus
special events as a lot of cool stuff
I'm sure you are all familiar with duck
typing in pipe in Python right if it
make the noise of a duck and it flies
like a duck it's probably a duck it
turns out that in C++ you can have the
same thing using templates and I show
you an example here we're on top you
have just a simple some Python regular
Python son it's a dot product on the
same in C++ which I'm sure you will
agree is a lot more beautiful using
templates takes two parameter l0 l1 and
then computes a sum using our own
template library and it does exactly the
same thing and buzz codes doesn't as
Hume they don't assume anything and the
arguments it just have to be terrible it
can be generator or it can be a list it
can be an array it can be whatever as
soon as you can as long as you can
iterate over it it will accept it you
can even pass one list and one array it
will box so the thing we don't support
is hit your genius container which means
if you give us a list it has to contain
either flowed see their integer or
whatever but you cannot have a list
which contains integer floats string and
so on so it has to be uniform just like
Mumbai array internally we unbox the
list in arrays before processing them so
that's how it works so C++ is a backhand
it's convenient because it's a
high-level language which means we can
do a lot of of stuff we have the rich
template library provided by the starter
we have object-oriented programming we
have metaprogramming I showed you a bit
of template and we have also type
inference now in C++ 11 you can use
Oh tokyo's and it will automatically
detect the type everywhere you don't
have to think about it and it's easier
for our code generation we have valdakk
template which is mind-blowing usually
but very convenient and C++ is also a
low-level background in some way there
are few hidden costs you don't pay for
what you don't use is free the motto of
C++ you have access to vector unit you
can write intrinsic directly and when I
say Victorian it and vector instruction
I'm really talking about what your CPU
as in one cycle it can compute
multiplication on four floats on modern
machine so you can really do that in a
in C++ good luck in Python it's good for
parallel programming also lot of library
lots of tools and even in the stand are
maybe in a few years the parallel stl
has just been proposed so let's dive
into the back end I'm joking just wanted
to see your face looks exactly like this
promise I will only do Python no more
C++ so static compilation we do static
completion because it saves times well
in that same time we have a lot of time
when we do static computation and by
static computation I mean not jet it's
hired of time we can take 10 seconds to
compile doesn't really matter if it's
online then well 10 seconds is a bit
long but then we can do a lot of
powerful optimization analyzes so you
only annotate the type in Python for the
exported function which means in terms
of public interface of your module the
function that has to be imported you
don't have to add any if you have a long
module and you annotate three function
you will be able to import the three
function in other modules and all the
other one will be kind of private they
won't be exported so I will talk about
some analysis so the analysis is the
part of patron where we gather a lot of
information by Tron is really modular
which means all analyzes they operate on
as visitor on jst and they can be
extracted from patron very easily
everything is combined with the past
manager at some point just like llvm
does if you know it so yeah some
analysis when Stan's points to point
selena is an analysis where you try to
know when you have an indium t fire here
are see where it can point to in memory
what parts of the memory it can refer
and here it can points to the memory of
a the memory of B or maybe a new memory
if a and B are just scholar for instance
and this is really an important
optimization analysis because it will
allow us to build other powerful
analysis on top of it so it's also
something very well known from sip C
compilers because of pointers and they
try to do it very hard it it's not an
easy opportunity analysis in general but
on most example we kind of we are able
to find out some other analysis that we
do is trying to find if a function is
pure that you're here it's just first if
a function will modify will have a side
effect on the arguments so here the
first function Fibonacci obviously
doesn't modify and so it's a side-effect
free on the argument and then bar apply
a map on Fibonacci and since the
compiler knows that fib is side-effect
free and the arguments it will infer
that bar is also which means that patron
builds a Cal graph and is able to do
these interprocedural analysis
propagating through the call graph all
these informations and it will deduce
that bar is side-effect free on L and
yeah we will propagate this through the
wall core graphene in Python and from
that we will build another analysis
which is pure function so what we call
pure function is purely side-effect free
which means side-effect free on its
arguments but also on the global state
of the program for instance here ab 0
is pure in what we call pure but f1 is
not because even though it calls a pure
function which is fine it's also called
print and prints as an i/o which is
considered as a global state why it
matters because when we do some map then
some map can be turned into parallel map
or not depending on the purity of the
function so python is able to detect
that and paralyze then some map
depending on the function we have used
their chains it's a classic compiler
analyzes its dependency analysis it
tried to find in the flow the control
flow where a definition of available
which means the results of a computation
will be used so we can sometimes
eliminate code that is useless or
reorganize codes changing the other of
the statements and preserving the
semantics of your program so what do we
do with all these analyzes and we have
some others but I won't have time to go
into detail we turn them into code
optimization so first example code
optimization is detection of false
polymorphism so we have trouble with
polymorphism polymorphism is available
that you will use as a string and later
as an integer and yeah so it costs a lot
of dynamic checking so you want to avoid
it so we try to statically type as much
as possible and for instance in this
code thanks to user chains we can see
that the first definition of a will
never reach the use of foo so we can
rename it using a zero fine stands and
only the two other definition of a will
reach foo and foo will be then perfectly
typed with an unable string so python is
able to detect that automatically and
any type in passion can be decade two
known so this is completely statically
typed another optimization is turned
iterator into lazy generator for
instance here we try to convert map into
I map
to save temporary allocation and be able
to build to reduce some expressions so
the first one can be easily turned into
imap and maybe you've got hint by the
function name the second one cannot be
turned into an IMAP this is because we
modify our later and we use it two times
in the return so if you were using an
IMAP they're the result would just be
not the same so we don't do it here so
by tran is able to detect these cases
and do it where were you where we can
other optimization it's constant folding
so this example is a bit contrived but
when you have a constant you've got a
function with a constant we can do a lot
of free compute at combined time and
this code will turn out to be a pure
static value at Indian we don't generate
any code at runtime that will be
executed at run time for that we get
directly the value so it happened a lot
of time when you have a constant global
constant you have some helper function
to combine those constant into a result
that you want it's usually not that
costly but when it is in a loop or at
the end of a call graph it will save you
function call it will save you if it's
what even if it's cheap if it's
1,000,000 times or 1 billion times and
operation well it's still a few percent
speed up that you can get ok so finally
after all these optimization we try to
do a little bit better and for that
nowadays you know it you don't get any
more free lunch process or doesn't offer
you any more frequency increased like it
was 10 years ago we are stuck at less
than three Giga giggles for most of us
but we have many calls so we need to
paralyze and we have many cars on each
of these cause of vector unit so if you
are able to use vector units and
paralyzation you can get a lot of speed
up so openmp is a standard which is well
known for many years
it's widely used and we support OpenMP
impact Ron so you can just add a comment
in front of a loop here OMP parallel for
and it tells the compiler that the loop
nest will be executed in parallel and it
will use multiple thread so python is
able to detect which viable are private
and which are shared so you don't have
to declare it automate your self it
saves you a bit of typing and well
that's convenient and you can see the
results with this loop i have a four
time speed up on my machine which are
which has a four course so that's pretty
good so without the without OpenMP we
have a 14 times speedup and with openmp
57 which is quite good and this is your
only thing we don't change anything in
the function except from adding
destroying people for and of course the
typing information for for the interface
some library level optimization so in
scientific computing numpy is key you do
I level are a manipulation many common
function are implemented this way so all
of these smells like Fortran and for
compare compiler guys like asphalt ron's
means performance for trans mini-z
vectorization validation and this is why
we are named by tron excuse me so site
on is known to be as fast as c so the
only way we could be faster we will be
to be as fast as fashion
so in the same way that new mex try to
save a temporary allocation and fusing
loops in an empire expression we do it
in C++ using expression templates so
well-known C++ meta programming
techniques which works well you build
some expression they are only evaluated
when you need the results so there is no
no loops it's kind of a loop fusion in
C++ it's very elegant we have some
vectorization using boosts simg and ng
too so all our operation I've written in
a way that the C++ compiler and this
library will be instantiated with the
most efficient instruction for your CPU
using AVX or s señor depending whatever
depending on you on your current machine
so right now we just in the process of
reorganizing the back end so we disabled
this vectorization but we ought to get
it back soon and the openmp support is
is there we also dropped the automatic
OpenMP which means that we don't when we
do a copy or some some we used to
automatically use OpenMP and also
because we are writing the back end we
also remove this far for now but it will
be back soon so some benchmark now first
a cite an example that we took from the
sci p let's type ii site on tutorial it
computes the Julia set and you can see
that patron is a little bit faster than
site on which is expected because it's
far on right and if we add OpenMP we can
even be a lot faster almost three times
faster than site on so yeah that's an
example on we didn't write it for patron
it's not I took it from site on so it
should be what site on knows to do the
same way I want it to be as fair as
possible so i took an example from numba
from a new material so it should
perfectly suit number
and it computes maunder maunder abroad
i'm sure you all know about mother
bought this is why i didn't put a
picture of this nice fractal ok i was
lazy this is why i didn't do it but
anyway well you see the results number
provides a now psalm 145 speed up and we
managed to a little bit faster i had to
use a GCC minus all fast to get it
because Nimba was a little bit faster
than us without that yeah the first
option had here i did it at five o'clock
this morning so yeah n queens dissolve
this famous problem where you have a
chessboard and you need to position the
Queen so that no one can attack each one
yeah well that's a chess problem anyway
we just have this example because we
want you to show some cool python stuff
not at school at the precipice of course
so we have a generator you can see that
we just often we have rewritten the
permutation the ETA throws fermentation
surely in python it's on the left you
don't don't use it it's just here to
show that we can do it and they are
yelled inside their list comprehension
and the right path there is the body of
an Queen solver there is set initialize
with this compression so it's really
pythonic I guess it's not like you have
to modify your code so that we can rien
de lit and we directly compile this with
a patron and I also use pie pie and you
can see that we are not as fast as Wi-Fi
on this example but that's not yeah we
are not also not far away from it so
it's quite interesting to see that we
have a good language support for for
Python under the subset that we support
is I think quite wide some benchmark so
those are non pie benchmark we didn't
write it usually we took them from many
sources and we combine them in a git
repository
I just have to run make and it will go
through all compilers using time it and
produce some results and yeah because I
really enjoyed the day here yesterday I
thought that last night I have to
produce a graph with matplotlib so
that's the first time i use matlab
matplotlib i hope you enjoy your results
maybe next time i will try also to put
some curls i heard that there is a spot
for that so take care that the scale is
logged starting in 20 yeah there are
some cool options in a in my problem you
can have a log scale at a certain point
so what you can see here is that so the
first column I should present the data
the first column the most dark one is
number the second one is patron and the
third one is parakeet and what you can
see is that tight Ron never slowdowns
your program on none of this case we
provide a slow down so a slow down is
when the curve goes down so the reason
towel kind of line is one everything is
normalized with respect to C Python and
we never oh yeah we slow down once on
the first example act eyes och distance
yeah I had to have one what we fail but
still we Nimbus some slow down parakeet
at some slow down on we don't we are not
always the fastest numba is the fastest
on to example parakeets also is the
fastest on three example I think but you
have the geometric mean at the end the
last column where you can see that we we
still have better results than what I
what we were able to get with those two
other compiler Nimba as something like
five times speedup overall and we are
closed closer to two
50 or 40 no no yeah the loss scale
doesn't have to read an i didn't find
with my plot able to put the numbers on
top of the column but that's will be for
next time yesterday I attended a very
nice talk about crushing the head of the
snake was in the other room I hope you
had the chance to see it if you deserve
then just check out the video i hope
we'll get it soon so i would have titled
it what every bite on easter should know
about python by the way because i think
you should everyone should know that
before writing code so i went through
the example that's yesterday evening I
river yeah just to see what patron can
do on that so this is the example at the
starting point where you can see that
the programme's do you don't know that
you can do a son in Python so on the top
left if wrote a total function doing its
own son which is completely obviously
slow well there are a lot of things that
you can do on this and I invite you to
have a look at this talk and the first
modification is is a very small one
where you just remove loop invariant so
if I can show you the first statement of
the loop on the right pops that can be
much can be moved out of the loop and
the same in the in the loop on the left
the bottom part the mean equal total
array / length of array can be moved out
of the loop and those two simple
modification is the only difference
between the first one and the second
column and you can see that we go from
very long time more than two minutes to
a few milliseconds so that's really
small modifications with a huge impact
and what I took from that is then you
should take from that is that you before
using a tool to optimize your code you
should just write good code in the first
place because python won't do magic it
will give you an I speed up like 100
times on your code you may be happy but
you've just moved two lines you will be
even faster than Python patron
yeah okay next week will be as fast as
as as the second version because this
transformation could be easily done by
python by the way this moving the
constant computation out of the loop so
that was a good idea that I had during
this talk yesterday we will improve
patron to end all this case and we
should be able to do four milliseconds
because just doing this transformation
in Python means we will get four
milliseconds and then with other
transformation that was applied to the
code the code was getting faster in
Python patrons II don't really care who
gets almost the same time as you can see
almost no change and finally when we get
to numpy array instead of list this is
where also we have another speed up so
yeah really you can see that even if by
Tron gives you and Ian a time speed up
writing good coats give you I don't know
a thousand times speedup something like
that so yeah the tool has to be in at
the end that's in the first place so I'm
almost at the end some engineering stuff
we use github it's an open source
project since the beginning we are open
to pull request but take care i'm very
picky with the code review we have a
dippy on repository we are very active
on IRC there is someone almost round the
clock especially because we are french
project but i live here so we have my
colleague in France I'm here with the
type different time frame we are round
the clock on IRC we also have a mailing
list that we used mostly for
announcements there is not much
discussion der everything is going on on
IRC it's available on pi pi is very easy
to install using easy install you it's
written in Python too we only use
support Python 2 by the way we don't
support Python 3 yet we have more than
2,000 test case in our regression shoot
it's run automatically every time a pro
request is issued all the code is Pat
eight and we support clunk GCC as a
background is validated on linux and OSX
so yeah it's very easy to it should be
quite easy to use so time for confusion
combining Python means more than typing
and translating a lot of optimization
that we can do in Python what next for
Python released apply the aversion and
for that may be a bit late it was
scheduled for last week but I didn't
specify which here so we are still up
for next year and I will be glad to come
back we want to support module imports
user module right now when you write
code in Python you've read this your
python module that you will compile it
cannot import code from other of your
module I already have a pull request
open for that so it should be there soon
you will be able to import just function
that are everywhere in your program and
get them into used into a single module
sometimes when we modify code we care
about performance but we don't always
run all the performance regressions hood
so we had a lot of regressions that's
really painful so we have an ongoing
work with a cut speed which is used by a
by PI thing to track a performance we
have to reenable vectorization because
that provides a huge boost usually and
yeah we need to be ahead ahead of number
and the other so we already need it we
need more imp I support I think we have
a very good support but probably will
disagree with me because I'm sure the
first example you will try you will use
done but not all the nimpah function
that we don't support and we also have
to start looking into side by that we
don't support at all right now and
because that was kind of I walked with
this during my PhD which was about
compiling automatically compiling code
for GPU we want to incorporate some
polyhedral transformation in patron that
would be really fun but while we are
working on this project on our free time
so probably it's going to be for another
life and that's the end of my talk thank
you for listening and I'm waiting for
questions
so earlier on you should that you can
take arbitrary iterators and do
optimizations for like maps on them what
are the restrictions and types of
generators or iterators you can actually
use because I imagine you can't just run
arbitrary Python generators uh why do I
mean by arbitrary by troc Python
generator so earlier you did stuff with
mapping over ranges or zipping over
ranges are there other types of
generators that you can automatically
optimize well I'm not sure I get the
question what we do is I talk about
these slides are those a lot prettier on
the map like paralyzing a map
automatically well we should bought an
EOP HR as long as we as we can prove
that that they are pure and that the map
the result of the map it depends on the
result of the map so it was this slide I
think yeah maybe so transforming this
map into I map also it's not ok I see
what you mean do whether we support we
support
filter map I don't have two full list in
my head okay so but here you basically
can only operate on lists or things that
can create lists like range so you can't
keep a xanex range here yeah you can by
the way we are turning a wrench into X
range when we can okay yeah this is a
yeah well I didn't mention it but
obviously we don't create temporaries we
are crazy about performance and to get
performance with to save memory because
this is what is low on your computer is
always the memory bandwidth most of the
time especially if you use a Python then
you have a lot of temporary arrays and
we try to save as much temporary
location as we can okay also something
we try to do because I'm talking about
memory is not to leak because many tools
around here are not playing well with
the Python garbage collector and we try
and we are I think almost there we have
a branch where we don't click we
shouldn't leak we are still testing it
but yeah the plan is that you can you
can run it into a software out of just
running a benchmark with time it in
command line you can keep it in your
process and it won't click memory to
questions about think you supporting
don't support because one of the slides
said we don't support this and the last
slide you said we don't support input so
in the past there was an issue with
Global's did you take care of it yeah we
have a pull request for that it's not
mesh there yet I yeah it's not yet merge
but right now you cannot have global
variables into in the patron module and
Sonja will be able to have it yeah okay
so soon it will go and what about the
import statements so is there if there's
a pipe of Python toggle with an import
of several libraries at the beginning do
you ignore them do you just don't
compile what yeah yeah we also something
with a with a
static computation is that you can fail
at compile-time provide an error message
saying we don't support this import
statement so we support import from many
modules built in modules Magnum PI
module you can import numpy of course in
Python code you can import mad you can
import those kind of module but what we
don't support is user module you write
your own module python code and so you
have to file and you want to import
function from one file on the other and
compile one of these two file with
patron so again this is a matter of week
because the pull request is open so just
a lot of things to do
a great talk uh what's the user
experience like in particular how dumb
can I be and still use Python both both
in the use of it and in the setup of it
well first you have to be not to them
because you will be in this situation
okay so at least you have to to know to
know python and then i think i show the
desire python session so to start with
to start with the only thing you you
have to do is add these type information
and the only so patron doesn't directly
use this type information it will
generate a C++ code but to be able to
compile the C++ code g + + need to
instantiate the template this is where
we use this for the interface between
Python and the code generated by patron
so you need to add one or multiple of
this statement the green statement that
you have on the screen so here it's the
declaration that the resin function will
be exported and you will be able to use
it with an array of float and this is
the only change i made to the code you
know I load the patron magic i exported
the function and that's it what about
installation is it dip in soluble can I
haven't even stopped by thermal oh yeah
yeah it's an usually install some pie
pie pie pie pie p all right bye-bye all
bye p I don't even know obviously okay
another question
yes
wait just father to make what are we
going
okay thanks for the great top I can so I
assume the code is compared to C++ first
right yes any use see past Paris
compiler to compile your code so i
assume that the compiler will differ as
well like if you're using g + + vs see
coming clean the hospice yeah what do
you generally suggest for for Python
program if if we just but both of them
are working fine you just need a recent
version which means GCC starting at
version for that eight and it's almost
two years old I think so standard
reasons but some linux distribution if
you other reddit finds dance you will be
stuck like five years with five years in
the best so you need a modern c++
compiler but bus clung on g+ plates are
used and we run the regression suit on
every pull request on bus of decompiler
so it both of them are well supported
some code i have a faster results with
clung it's obviously if i start to
compile the code plunk it gives you nice
nicer warning i really prefer clown and
use it as much as possible but sometimes
g + + is a faster you know so it depends
c++ computation and computation in
general is that is a bit of dark magic i
showed you this example we're just
changing the minus all fast 4G plus plus
gave me better results it was like
twenty percent faster with this minus of
fast then minus 0 to that i use a
usually so well you have to try we have
a python comes with a configuration file
and in your home directory you can just
have a configuration file where you are
you change the compiler and you change
the flag that you want to pass to a
compiler i can show you maybe what it
looks like so
me see if I can zoom that's a nice Mac
feature so that's my patron I'll see and
yeah I just have some specific paths
because i use a mac and i didn't start
boost in the standard hour plus i use n
star boost with a pot and then some flag
and you can see that i have my
alternative configuration with GCC and
right now i'm using a musta clown so i
just change the flag here test it the by
default you don't have to create this
file Itron as a default configuration
that should work fine on mask on
configuration just if you want to tune
it so we are out of time so if you want
to ask question i'm still open and i'm
there i will be there for lunch and so
on so thank you for attending